WASHINGTON.
I'M BRET BAIER.
THE NEW AMERICAN EMBASSY TO
ISRAEL IS OPEN TONIGHT IN
JERUSALEM.
AND THAT IS SPARKING A WIDE
RANGE OF EMOTIONS.
FROM JUBILATION AMONG ISRAEL
AND ITS SUPPORTERS IN THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION, TO
DEADLY RAGE FROM
PALESTINIANS.
AND THEIR SUPPORTERS
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
WHILE THE PRESIDENT'S
DAUGHTER IVANKA FRONTED A
HUGE DELEGATES FROM HER
FATHER'S OFFICE,
PALESTINIANS CLASHED WITH
ISRAELI TROOPS ON THE GAZA
BORDER RESULTING IN DOZENS
OF DEATHS AND THOUSANDS OF
INJURIES.
THAT IS WHERE WE START
TONIGHT WITH CORRESPONDENT
BENJAMIN HALL.
♪ O SAY CAN YOU.
>> A CAMPAIGN PROMISE
FULFILLED TODAY AND WITH
GREAT FANFARE AS THE NEW
U.S. EMBASSY OPENED IN
JERUSALEM.
25 YEARS AFTER AMERICA FIRST
PLEDGED TO DO SO.
>> WHAT A GLORIOUS DAY.
REMEMBER THIS MOMENT
[APPLAUSE]
PRESIDENT TRUMP, BY
RECOGNIZING HISTORY, HAVE
YOU MADE HISTORY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THERE WAS A SIZEABLE U.S.
DELEGATES.
AMONG THEM IVANKA TRUMP AND
JARED KUSHNER.
STEVEN MNUCHIN AND VARIOUS
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
ALTHOUGH THE PRESIDENT WAS
NOT IN ATTENDANCE HE
ADDRESSED THE CEREMONY BY
VIDEO LUNCH LINK.
CONGRATULATIONS IT'S BEEN A
LONG-TIME COMING.
THE UNITED STATES WILL
ALWAYS BE A GREAT FRIEND OF
ISRAEL AND A PARTNER IN THE
CAUSE OF FREEDOM.
AND PEACE.
>> NOT EVERYONE WAS
CELEBRATING.
53 THREE MILES SOUTH THE
MOVE INFLAMED THE PROTESTS
IN GAZA.
SOME 40,000 PALESTINIANS
STAGED DEMONSTRATIONS ALONG
THE BORDER WITH ISRAEL
LEADING TO DEADLY CLASHES.
OVER 50 PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
MORE THAN 2300 WOUNDED.
>> THIS HAS BEEN THE BIGGEST
PROTEST CARRIED OUT BY THE
PALESTINIANS SINCE THE
PROTESTS BEGAN SIX WEEKS
AGO.
IT'S ALSO SEEN THE BIGGEST
RESPONSE FROM THE ISRAELIS,
MAKING THIS THE DEADLIEST
DAY SINCE THE WAR IN 2014.
>> ISRAELI MILITARY
OFFICIALS SAY THEY FOILED
SEVERAL COORDINATED ATTEMPTS
BY PALESTINIANS TO BREACH
THE FENCE, PUSHING THEM BACK
WITH LIVE FIRE.
THEY ALSO CARRIED OUT
AIRSTRIKES ON HAMAS CAMPS,
HAVING WARNED THE
PALESTINIANS IN ADVANCE.
>> WE HAVE TO BE VERY CLEAR
AND SHARP AND IF NEEDED
FORCEFUL TO DEFEND OUR
BORDER BECAUSE ISRAELI
CIVILIANS' LIVES ARE AT
STAKE.
>> PALESTINIAN LEADERS SAY
THE MOVE HAS ENDED THEIR
TRUST IN AMERICA.
FORCING THEM TO WALK AWAY
FROM PEACE TALKS.
>> WE CONSIDER THAT
AMERICA'S MOVING OF THE
EMBASSY MEANS THE END OF
AMERICAN CONTROL OF THE
PEACE TALKS.
WE WILL NOT GO BACK AGAIN TO
AN AMERICAN LED PEACE TALKS.
>> MORE PROTESTS ARE PLANNED
TOMORROW TO COMMEMORATE WHAT
PALESTINIANS CALL THE
CATASTROPHE OF THE CREATION
OF THE JEWISH STATE.
BUT, IN ISRAEL TODAY, LITTLE
COULD DAMPEN THE JOY AT
AMERICA'S CLEAR SIGN OF
COMMITMENT TO THEM.
A SENTIMENT SHARED ACROSS
POLITICAL DIVIDES.
AND EVEN SENATE MINORITY
LEADER CHUCK SCHUMER PRAISED
THE PRESIDENT FOR MOVING THE
EMBASSY.
SAYING HE APPLAUDED
PRESIDENT TRUMP FOR DOING
SO.
AND IN TWO COUNTRIES,
GUATEMALA AND PAIR GUY HAVE
SAID THEY WILL FOLLOW SUIT
AND MOVE THEIR EMBASSY TO
JERUSALEM.
NEWS JUST BREAKING IN THE
LAST FEW HOURS, TURKEY HAS
JUST ANNOUNCED IT IS GOING
TO PUT OUT ITS AMBASSADOR TO
THE U.S.
BOTH IN RESPONSE TO THE
EMBASSY.
THAT IS A BIG DIPLOMATIC